[Applaudissements]
mais depuis que je suis militaire ce
n'est pas rigolo entre nous je suis une
santé précaire et je me fais un gros
c'est s'en fout pas très beau vouloir me
remonter je souffre de tous les côtés
j'ai la rate qui se dilate c'est le
point qui est pas droit j'ai le ventre
qui se rentrent chez le pilote qui se
colorent chez le dossier anémiée
l'estomac bien trop bas et les cotes
bien trop hautes et les enjeux qui se
démanteler pigasse qui s'encastrent
l'abdomen qui s'est même gilles thorax
qui se désaxe à katherine kiss débit ne
léser pour le qui se frôlent vieux les
reins bien trop faim les boyaux bien
trop gros qu'est ce qu'un homme qui se
décolle mais le sacrum c'est tout comme
jay le nom brille tout en vrille et le
coccyx qui se dévissent à vos excès s'en
mettront d'être toujours patrac à
beauduc c'est embêtant ce type pas bien
portant
afin de guérir au plus vite un matin
tout dernièrement je suis allé un lundi
site par le major du régime en a partout
souffrez-vous qui m'a commandé
c'est bien simple que j'ai répliqué et g
lara textile a pris une fois qu'ils
aient pas 3g le ventre qui se rendre
chez le pilote qui se colorent du gosier
à meinier l'estomac bien trop bas et les
côtes bien trop hot chili en ce qu'ils
démentent chez les picards qui
s'encastrent l'ap de même 10 mn sur le
thorax qui se désaxe la poterie de crise
des bises les épaules qui se prolonge je
les rends notre offrant les boyaux bien
trop gros j'espère noctis dégommer le
sacrum c'est tout comme
j'ai le nombril tout en vrille et le coq
s'esquisse davis et puis les ajouter
voyez vous ce n'est pas tout j'ai les
genoux qui sont mougel ses murs quai
trop dur j'ai les cuisses qui seraient
10 et les guiboles qui flageolent chez
les ch tis tortillait les rotules qui
ondule des tibias raplapla les mollets
tropez des orteils pas pareil c'est le
coeur en largeur les poumons tout en
long l'occiput qui chahutent eux les
coudes qui se dessine chez les saints
sous le bassin et bassac et passa en
plus sales vous le cache pas j'ai aussi
quels soucis
la lune est trop plus est le chauffage
qui surnage les gencives qui dérivent
jules fallait que pollet mais les dents
c'est navrant j'ai les petites qui
s'irrite et les grosses qui se
déchaussent les canines se ratatine les
molaires sont la peur dans les yeux pour
mieux que le droit qui est un droit et
le gauche c'est bien moche j'ai les cils
qui se défilent les sourcils qui
s'épilent tulle menton est trop long la
paire propre et prg le net ou boucher le
trou du cookie ceux des coûts et du
courrier vous je suis gêné pour par des
sélections car maintenant je suis forcé
de m'arrêter
des travaux et par département
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]